You can stop going to eBay for your Twinkie fix because they're back!
The iconic American junk food returns to store shelves on July 15th...
...in what its new owners are calling the sweetest comeback in the history of ever.
Beleaguered Hostess Brands went bankrupt last November...
...after it couldn't come to terms with its unionized workforce,...
...leading to a halt in production which caused a Twinkie panic last year.
Private equity firms Metropoulos & Co. and Apollo Global Management...
...purchased the rights to Twinkie and other Hostess cakes.
The new owners are banking on Twinkie's nostalgic cult following...
...for a blockbuster boom in sales this summer.